[Musique]
frontière franco-belge 4h32 le retour de
boite a tourné au fait
diversé la mission d'un journaliste sur
ce type d'événements faire le plein
d'image et récolter le maximum de
renseignements
le journaliste fait diversifié tentera
de dépasser les limites qui lui sont
imposées
pour témoigner sur film ou papier du
drame qui vient de se dérouler
[Musique]
une banlieue bourgeoise de région
parisienne le quartier est tranquille
mais la veille au soir un homme a tué
ses voisins et leurs invités pour des
histoires de bruit quatre personnes dont
une femme enceinte ont péri criblés de
balles sous les yeux de leurs enfants le
drame a fait l'ouverture des JT de la
matinée mais si tôt dans la journée le
frère du meurtrier n'a pas encore écouté
les actualités
justement c'est là le problème c'est
pour ça que je m'inquiète je vois des
caméras partout je vois la télé alors
c'est pour ça que
de couple
ah là ça m'inquiète sérieusement vous
commencez à m'inquiéter sérieusement le
frère et sa femme sont venus rendre une
simple visite de courtoisie à leurs
proches ils arrêtaient
alors comme il était un peu à la longue
il est devenu déplacer
toutes les rédactions sont au courant
depuis plusieurs heures mais le couple
n'a même pas été prévenu de nouveau
c'est un journaliste qui le révèle
l'épilogue du fait divers
[Musique]
les dernières télévisions désertent les
lieux c'est vrai que ça tout de suite
beaucoup d'impact médiatique parce que
ça suscite beaucoup d'émotions tout de
suite quatre personnes qui se font tuer
dans une résidence comme ça plutôt calme
donc c'est quelque chose sur lequel on
doit être présent faut essayer de pas
trop en faire on a les familles de
victimes qui arrivent faut pas non plus
on va pas nous faire des gros plans sur
des gens en train de pleurer qui
viennent d'apprendre la mort de leurs
proches difficile toujours de
positionner la balance pas trop en faire
il faut quand même être présent pour
d'autres journalistes le travail
commence à peine Bruno ledion le
reporter du nouveau détective un hebdos
spécialisé fait divers a besoin de
beaucoup de matière sur l'affaire ici
pas de concierge mais c'est tout comme
ce voisin a tout vu et tout entendu
quatrième à l'hôpital et puis il s'est
suicidé et la femme elle est morte avec
le bébé à l'hôpital
[Musique]
aucun mystère dans la chronologie des
faits le meurtrier monte il sonne on lui
ouvre et il fait peu à 11 reprises avant
de retourner son arme contre lui
les crimes les plus simples Russell
parfois une sombre ironie du sort un
ingrédient classique pour pimenter le
récit du fait divers le témoin est
intarissable Bruno ledion commence à en
savoir plus sur les victimes
elle travaillait à Villemomble et lui il
était dans l'informatique
[Musique]
alors que Bruno poursuit ses
investigations il apprend que la
rédaction a dénicher une photo de la
victime sur internet il faut recouper
l'information direction à cybercafé avec
le témoin dont la disponibilité semble
sans limite
pose la cible et bikini
il ne s'agit pas de la victime
bon ben tant pis le fait divers suscite
l'interrogation des riverains et la
curiosité d'un autre quidam qui vient de
loin 4 morts
par la suite
on éclate
le fait divers fait aujourd'hui l'objet
d'étude université docteur en lettres
marclitz et professeur de communication
à l'Université de Louvain en Belgique il
est directeur de l'Observatoire du récit
médiatique
ceux qui ont le terrain il faut vraiment
avec leur carnet ils prennent des notes
et il y a pas un nom qui manque il y a
pas la couleur d'une façade qui manque
une marque de voiture non mais c'est un
vrai travail d'investigation et très
écrit parce qu'on raconte à fait divers
c'est pas un récit comme les autres
faits divers parce que vraiment lu parce
que ça nous parle de ce qu'est notre vie
ça met en scène nos peurs et on sait
qu'au milieu dans un monde très
anxiogène et peut-être de plus en plus
anxiogène qu'on a peut être qu'on peut
arriver et raconter ces histoires ou
lire ce qui racontait pas journaliste ça
me permet d'exorciser mes peurs une
espèce de catharsis qui fait que en
lisant cela d'une part je me rends
compte ça arrive à d'autres et en même
temps c'est un objet social parce que je
peux en parler je vais faire mes courses
sur le boucher tu as vu ce qui s'est
passé dans le journal ce qu'on a dit on
en discute ça me permet de d'un peu
réguler cette angoisse si on prend la
presse régionale l'essentiel les faits
divers c'est les accidents au coin de la
rue celle cycliste qui est tombé de son
vélo c'est la petite vieille qui se fait
arracher son sac c'est pas un événement
qui a une emploi extraordinaire un autre
des trait du fait divers c'est aussi la
proximité quotidien des gens
[Musique]
le centre ville de Saint-Quentin dans
l'Aisne un événement retient ce matin
l'attention des passants des travaux sur
une canalisation et un conducteur qui
n'a pas remarqué le trou occasionné sur
la chaussée olivier est un fait
diversifié de laine nouvelle le journal
local
la pêche aux infos commencent première
source en présence la police municipale
excusez
quand même un peu de gaz
Olivier engage ensuite la conversation
avec l'automobile liste distrait
honnêtement vous le voyez pas
qu'il y a un trou honnêtement OK
je peux juste vous demander votre âge
le conducteur de 58 ans
puis ça tire du monde en centre-ville
voilà on fera un petit truc c'est plutôt
un fait divers c'est un peu entre
guillemets quoi sauf pour le monsieur
mais bon plutôt insolite
petit événement dans l'histoire ça
s'engage peut-être une fuite des mesures
sont pratiquées par les pompiers
préventivement la rue est interdite à la
circulation quelques photos s'imposent
[Musique]
je profite aussi pour faire quelques
gros plans sur les pompiers pour leur
donner les photos
j'aime bien
encore quelques questions à poser et
Olivier disposera de toutes les
informations nécessaires à l'écriture de
son papier
[Musique]
lent à une cinquantaine de kilomètres de
au palais de justice depuis le début de
la semaine on juge un homme pour le
meurtre d'un autre parmi les principaux
acteurs du procès la fille de la victime
c'est la partie civile
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de ce procès
qu'il soit condamné un maximum et qui
souffre jusqu'à la fin de sa vie comme
moi j'ai souffert de la perte de mon
père
les crimes de sang sont jugés par les
tribunaux d'assises des lieux propices à
l'exacerbation des patients
Magali filou est une autre journaliste
de laine nouvelle elle couvre l'audience
pour le quotidien c'est le dernier jour
d'audience aujourd'hui
on a retrouvé l'arme du crime qui figure
parmi les pièces à conviction les faits
ne sont pas contestés massacre aux pieds
de biche puis défenestration de la
victime l'affaire semble simple mais le
procès ne l'est pas notamment regarde la
condition mentale de lacusé
[Musique]
après trois mois de coma et très
lourdement handicapé il a par la suite
connu une vie très difficile
d'institution psychiatrique on a
l'avocat de la partie civile donc qui
représente la fille du défunt qui
pose très clairement la question de la
capacité
intellectuelle et la capacité
éventuellement à manipuler de l'accusé
c'est pas du tout facile à
[Musique]
35 ans
sans profession
vous pouvez vous asseoir mesdames
messieurs
les journalistes présents ont pour
mission de faire la chronique judiciaire
leur compte-rendu d'audience sont-ils
quelqu'un fluence sur l'issue du procès
l'avocat de la défense insurgent ainsi
contre la Une de l'aide nouvelle
quelques jours plus tôt une citation de
l'accusé je suis un monstre il l'a dit
mais pourquoi le sortir comme ça quatre
colonnes à la une et un samedi
c'est-à-dire le jour le jour de du plus
grand tirage alors bon s'ils veulent
vendre qui n'utilisent pas les gens les
plus défavorisés pour moi c'était un
élément émotionnel très fort aussi du
procès le choix qui est fait baisser la
soirée on peut discuter chaque jour ou
après jour du type de une après c'est
aussi des bonnes guerres chacun utilise
les médias dans son propre intérêt
probablement effectivement que un titre
comme celui-là ne sert pas forcément les
dessins de l'avocat de la défense qui
d'ailleurs a fait à mon sens une
plaidoirie extrêmement humaine
en fin de journée les débats sont
terminés les jurés la présidente du
tribunal vont délibérer un temps mis à
profit par les journalistes pour
commencer la rédaction de leurs articles
le meilleur façon de traiter les assises
consiste à s'en éloigner sans doute
c'est-à-dire à ne pas être prisonnier
des débats à raconter ce qui se passe
pour ceux qui sont là mais surtout pour
ceux qui n'y sont pas donc quand il y a
cinq experts qui défilent à la barre si
ce qu'ils n'ont à dire ce qu'ils ont à
dire n'a aucun intérêt on en parle pas
on est là pour raconter une histoire et
il faut pas avoir honte de le dire et de
l'expliquer on raconte une histoire
cette histoire touche à sa fin le
verdict est tombé pour David Carpentier
reconnu coupable condamnés
Magalie rentre au journal pour faire le
point avec le secrétaire de rédaction
[Musique]
verdict final 20 ans c'était très très
fort parce que tous la défense a fait un
réquisitoire très humain très très
humain où elle est rappelé les fêtes que
c'était un homme qui était jugé par
monstre contrairement
ça va faire la Une le titre de une ça
c'est sûr
qui est en général consacré au fait
divers de toute façon aujourd'hui
ça se produit très rarement très
rarement là on est un peu surpris et
c'est vrai que ça se produit très
rarement donc là du coup le bon on a
retourne notre fait divers de une avec
les assises parce que c'était un fait
divers assez important et dans le
bandeau où il y a toujours un fait
divers secondaire on dirait entre
guillemets bon bah là ça sera un appel
de sport on le voit le consacrer au
sport
le lendemain c'est une nouvelle journée
d'actualité locale qui commence à l'aide
nouvelle chaque matin il est un rituel
immuable dans le bureau du rédacteur en
chef
première réflexe le matin c'est de c'est
pas de regarder mon canard c'est de
regarder la concurrence en l'occurrence
l'Union
et le Courrier Picard moi ce qui
m'intéresse
sont les sujets de local mais aussi les
faits divers en matière de faits divers
parce que redoute tous les journalistes
ce sont les ratages et là manifestement
on en a pas
donc tout ça c'est un autre secteur
comme de nombreux titres la nouvelle est
originellement un journal de résistant
fondé à la Libération le fait divers a
toujours occupé une place importante
dans ses colonnes il y a deux façons un
petit peu de considérer les faits divers
soit cette fameuse rubrique des chiens
écrasés qui n'a aucune noblesse soit
c'est un baromètre social
sociétal comme dit certains de notre
environnement
dans la zone de diffusion de l'aide
nouvelle le monde rural est prédominant
couvrir l'actualité des petites
campagnes reculé nécessite l'emploi de
journalistes non professionnel les
correspondants
on va voir Michel Berdal Michel Berdal
c'est un correspondant qui est
sur le canton du Catelet
couvrant un secteur assez important pour
nous un secteur ou
la nouvelle et son vrai concurrence
et c'est un type qui a le l'effet divers
Chevilly au corps il adore ça
[Musique]
il soulève la nuit pour aller couvrir
les accidents il est autant avec un
nombre incalculable de gendarmes
c'est sans aucun doute notre plus
précieux correspondant en termes de
faits évident
Michel Berdal étant disponibilité de la
poste c'est le type qui connaît tout le
monde dans le coin sur tous les
gendarmes et les pompiers chaque jour il
fait sa tournée cette nuit un incendie
pas loin de la source électrique quoi
donc c'est le matelas
donc là le risque c'est pour nous le
risque c'est l'embrasement généralisé si
on vend t-il pas
nous ça veut pas dire que ça fait parler
des pompiers de freinant mais ça prouve
qu'on est toujours là qu'on est toujours
présent pas n'importe quelle heure
n'importe quel temps quoi les gens sont
capables de voir que les pompiers à
n'importe quelle heure on intervient
[Musique]
retour au journal dans le bureau des
faits diversiers Olivier se fait
confirmer l'horaire de l'audience qu'il
doit couvrir dans l'après-midi au
tribunal de Saint-Quentin 15 heures très
bien merci au revoir
les crimes les délits le drame humain
compose l'essentiel du quotidien neuf et
diversifié
au fil des papiers et des années le
journaliste a appris à prendre du recul
au regard de cette actualité
particulière les premières
expérimentales que j'ai fait ici sous le
sous la bâche c'est un gamine
de 4 ans
je le dis là on s'identifie après c'est
là il faut garder le recul aussi je vais
pas je vais pas ça pas empêcher de
dormir la nuit il faut dire skier quoi
c'est que j'appelle ma femme et mon fils
vient de me rattacher me dire bon tout
le monde va bien chez vous et après ça
repart
[Musique]
au palais de justice de Saint-Quentin
Olivier retrouve Bernard Dordogne l'un
de ses confrères travaillant pour un
journal concurrent
ici il croise les personnages parfois
truculents qui peuplent l'univers de la
justice ordinaire
[Rires]
développent souvent une sévère addiction
au téléphone portable oui commissaire
une bonne dose d'ondes électromagnétique
est nécessaire avant le sevrage de
l'audience
[Musique]
à l'étage Olivier croise le nouveau
procureur vous dire qu'on ne prend pas
en compte l'aspect médiatique d'un
dossier c'est stupide pourquoi parce
qu'il y a évidemment des considérations
d'or public si vous avez une affaire qui
prend une ampleur ou donne le sentiment
qu'on font justice n'a pas été rendu le
risque c'est que les nos concitoyens se
justice eux-mêmes donc il faut aussi
intégrer dans nos pratiques judiciaires
la nécessité d'une lisibilité de notre
action pour éviter des difficultés avant
le procès les journalistes fait
diversifier attendre patiemment entre
confrères l'entente et cordiale même si
le jeu de la concurrence consiste à
sortir des infos que les autres n'ont
pas
sur ce papier oui
[Musique]
au programme de cet après-midi un homme
accusé d'avoir giflé une adolescente de
sa cité il est jugé en comparution
immédiate c'est la justice Express sont
ses désengorger des tribunaux procédure
ultra rapide verdict dans moins de 2
heures quand vient le délibérer c'est
l'heure de la popote avec les policiers
sujet brûlant du moment un fait divers
sensible une brebis galeuse chez les
poulets
la couverture de l'affaire a valu à tous
les faits diversifié du cru
l'interdiction d'entrer dans les
commissariats de police de la région
la mise en examen et au placement des
tensions d'un policier et effectivement
à la suite à la suite de la couverture
de ce fait divers
il a été manifestement décidée
la claque vaut 8 mois ferme à la fusée
précision d'importance une mention
d'homicide figuré déjà sur son casier il
s'attendait à prendre ses quartiers à la
maison d'arrêt
après la fin de l'audience la journée
d'olivier est encore loin d'être
terminée première étape une rapide
tournée chez les pompiers juste le temps
de prendre quelques notes sur une
intervention des sapeurs dans un cours
d'eau de 300 litres de fioul DRC
itherne qui a débordé en cours
mais ce qu'attendait vraiment Olivier
aujourd'hui c'est son rendez-vous avec
le commissaire de Saint-Quentin il a
contourné l'interdiction fait au
journaliste de pénétrer dans les
commissariats ça faisait longtemps que
tu étais pas rentrer dans ce
commissariat dans le saint des saints
là j'y vais pour un truc institutionnel
pour présenter les Journées de la
sécurité intérieure comme du samedi donc
officiellement je n'y vais pas pour la
tournée des faits divers
le hall d'un commissariat est une source
d'information à lui tout seul
historique qui traîne
des choses à
partires
etc puis tout le monde est affolé
effectivement il y avait un
exhibitionniste qui traînait aux abords
d'un collège
donc le lendemain papier tout seul à
l'avoir monsieur j'étais le seul
[Musique]
Olivier a rendez-vous avec le
commissaire de Saint-Quentin en personne
Nicolas Boileau 32 ans ce n'est pas lui
qui a pris la mesure de bannissement des
journalistes mais son supérieur
hiérarchique Nicolas introduit la
conversation par un papier dont il n'est
pas très satisfait à partir du moment où
il y a marquage au sol la place n'est
que pour les personnes au militaires
réduites tranches la police de
Saint-Quentin quand il veut contacter et
bien gentil mais comme il y a que moi
qui parle à la presse je sais très bien
que il a pas appelé ici non non
au fil du temps et de l'actualité
judiciaire qui passe une certaine
complicité s'est installée entre le
policier et le journaliste
[Rires]
très vite Olivier ombraille sur la
tournée des faits divers mais la
discussion est interrompue par un coup
de fil familier c'est le fait diversifié
de l'Union monsieur qui vient au
mauvaise nouvelle
en réunion si tu veux quatre jeunes qui
ont pénétré dans les lieux sont en train
de voler le cuivre donc là je suppose
pas les bonnes questions 18 ans pour les
trois et tu peux le 4e 19 ok merci à
plus bye
[Musique]
il est maintenant temps d'évoquer les
détails de la journée de promotion de
samedi Nicolas Boileau compte beaucoup
sur la presse locale pour médiatiser
l'événement c'est une des clés du succès
de cette opération jour le volet
recrutement parce que ça reste des
institutions qui reprennent beaucoup
même si en ce moment un peu moins mais
qui ont toujours une manière
complètement ancienne et puis on aura
une tente quoi de nous un gros stand sur
la police technique et scientifique
le jeune commissaire et le journaliste
trentenaire semble conscient
d'appartenir en fait à un même monde le
complexe médiatico judiciaire bonne
soirée
[Musique]
sa cathédrale
dans la ville du champagne une autre
institution le journal L'Union un grand
quotidien régional contempler d'une
centaine de journalistes salariés fort
d'une dizaine de reporters et d'un
photographe à titré le service des faits
divers est bien doté
Eric Lenné est l'un de ses responsables
pour se reporter à chevronné pas de
mystère le turbain c'est d'abord sur le
terrain que ça se passe c'est une
histoire donc il faut essayer de la il
faut essayer de la mettre en scène de
d'amener le lecteur sur le terrain et
dans le fait divers donc pour ça il faut
il faut beaucoup de détails c'est aussi
pour ça qu'il faut aller sur le terrain
et qu'il faut essayer de recueillir un
maximum d'éléments pour essayer de
recréer une ambiance et essayer de
mettre le plus possible le lecteur dans
cette ambiance là direction soit sur le
terrain d'un braquage avec Aurélie
Brossard une journaliste du service
directement elle se rend chez la victime
un commerçant qui tient un hôtel bar
c'est magnifique il y a pas de lumière
on a appris que vous aviez été victime
d'un vol avec violence hier
on voulait savoir s'il serait possible
vous nous racontiez un petit peu comment
ça s'est passé
en commission de police que je voulais
pas que ça va résoudre le journal ça ne
marche jamais comme ça les les policiers
les gendarmes doivent pas nous interdire
de de faire un papier qu'on a
l'information
dessus d'accord
est-ce que vous avez peur j'ai un peu
peur oui parce que quand vous en trouvez
qu'un couteau sous la gorge
magnifique ce qui est appliqué forcément
vous avez pas envie que ça se sache et
j'ai pas envie que ça recommence non bah
on vous en fait pas plus longtemps merci
au revoir
pour plus d'infos l'enquête de voisinage
l'armurier bonne idée oui ça va si vous
aviez vu ou entendu quelque chose
plusieurs commerçants
pour la police OK et ben on vous embête
pas plus longtemps merci
bon courage au revoir
Aurélie n'est pas du genre à abandonner
facilement une source d'informations
potentielle
[Applaudissements]
mais dans ce bar du coin on fait celui
qui n'entend pas
Castle tienne la récolte se poursuit au
garage d'à côté ils nous ont dit quoi
alors les pousser quand ils sont passés
entre la jeune femme et le fait divers
c'est une histoire qui remonte à
l'enfance
et je commençais à apprendre à lire
je lisais je la vois du Nord et les
pages faits divers sur les genoux en
papier
2 heures de terrain plus tard et la
journaliste en sait maintenant un peu
plus sur la façon dont on opérer les
malfaiteurs il est temps de rentrer à la
rédaction
[Musique]
ton bureau se trouve à Laon ou l'Union
dispose d'une agence elle doit d'abord
joindre le commissaire de Soissons pour
confronter son enquête de terrain à
celle effectuée par la police
le fait qu'ils aient opéré un visage
découverte pour vous ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que
non je pense que ça va faire une
ouverture ce que nous on appelle une
ouverture une tête c'est le papier
principal
[Musique]
18h c'est l'heure de la Réunion dans le
bureau du responsable de l'édition
départementale pour faire le point sur
les faits divers du jour la menacé avec
un couteau sous la gorge l'autre a mis
la main dans dans son pantalon et a pris
l'enveloppe qui était sans caleçon qui
contenait 1500 euros pas d'appel à
témoin les autres faits diversifiés du
secteur ont déjà fait leur rapport au
chef de l'édition on cherche à savoir si
le quartier sous la coupe d'un Pyroman
ou pas 50 ans oui et il a une autre
petite histoire dans roumain qui a volé
du matériel iPhone dans une grande
surface pour 2000 euros donc
Aurélie commence la rédaction de son
article l'écriture une gymnastique
quotidienne un journaliste de presse
régionale noirci des centaines de pages
chaque année
Marie-Pierre Duval est secrétaire de
rédaction SR un maillon essentiel de la
chaîne de réalisation de la journal les
SCR hiérarchisent l'information et sont
également en charge de la vérification
des papiers en SR expérimenté
Marie-Pierre accorde une attention
particulière aux faits divers
la journée d'un fait diversité commence
de bonheur à se termine très tard et
puis on est toujours au plus près de la
foudre donc on cherche toujours à voir
les dernières informations et c'est la
difficulté parce que justement ce sont
des papiers sensibles des papiers qui
sont très lus où on peut déraper très
vite et qu'on reçoit qu'on traite dans
l'urgence on a quand même régulièrement
des petits des petits détails Hermès des
la présomption d'innocence et le respect
de la victime aussi moi je suis très à
cheval là-dessus j'aime pas beaucoup les
identités de victimes parce que déjà on
est victime c'est pas la peine de l'être
de foi
il est 23h15 Aurélie baisse les stores
ferme les portes et éteint les lumières
avec la force de l'habitude demain est
un autre jour
[Musique]
le lendemain direction Saint-Quentin des
pompiers s'affairent à la
désincarcération d'une victime d'un
accident de la route d'autres sapeur
habillés en bibendum interviennent sur
une alerte pollution chimique c'est la
foire aux faits divers de simples
exercices bien sûr les badauds sont en
fait des spectateurs et les blessés de
jeunes acteurs
c'est la journée de la sécurité et de la
prévention la grande kermesse des
pinsons casquette képi et Giro de thon
il fait beau et les démonstrations
reçoivent les faveurs des 50 inois comme
vous pouvez le constater en direct le
dépistage d'alcoolisme le conducteur du
véhicule est particulièrement
récalcitrant nécessitant une inter une
intervention musclée des fonctionnaires
de police qui parviennent finalement à
le maîtriser parmi les spectateurs on
retrouve Aurélie Olivier qui sont
évidemment de la partie c'est un peu de
la comme je peux pas se cacher c'est de
la comme pour eux mais bon c'est parti
du jeu quoi il s'agit bien retranscrire
ce qu'ils ont fait
un gendarme à la place d'un policier et
vice-versa on a déjà eu le coup l'année
dernière
au détour d'un exercice Aurélie la fait
Diversière de l'Union en profite pour
discuter avec le directeur départemental
de la sécurité publique c'est lui qui a
banni les journalistes des commissariats
de la région et il n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer devant notre caméra
mais Nicolas Boileau le commissaire de
Saint-Quentin lui se prête volontiers
aux jeux des photos et de la promo
[Musique]
une zone industrielle de Reims l'Union
est dispose d'un bâtiment qu'on appelle
l'usine la nuit commence à peine ici
s'établit la réalisation finale du
journal chacune des pages est traitée
selon une chaîne dont les maillons sont
des journalistes ou des techniciens les
unes sont visées avec un soin
particulier
sur l'autoroute en plus petit donc je
lui ai demandé d'inverser de mettre plus
gros 100000 euros de cocaïne et sur
l'autoroute en plus petit une autoroute
n'est pas très intéressante 100000 € de
code ça devient un peu plus intéressant
l'Union c'est 9 éditions différentes
d'un même titre quant à l'impression il
suffit d'emprunter la porte d'à côté
voici l'engin une rotative flambant
neuve 25 millions d'euros investis par
le groupe R100 média
discret géant de la presse française qui
détient des dizaines de quotidiens et
périodiques régionaux d'ailleurs outre
l'Union ici on imprime également la
quasi-totalité des autres journaux du
coin en fait on a regroupé tous les tous
les journaux de la région
Champagne-Ardenne on a pu les petits
journaux qui sont un peu disséminaires
un peu partout
les petites entreprises familiales qui
faisaient leur petit journal pour la
pour 100% départements ou pour ça
par rapport au système économique actuel
de toute façon petite entreprise
aujourd'hui qui avait un journal elle
pouvait plus vivre c'était pas possible
par rapport à ce que ça demande comme
comme modernisation
c'est des moyens énormes donc seul un
gros groupe investir dans des moyens
le regroupement ou la mort voit la
résumé la donne de l'économie de la
presse régionale entre crise du lectorat
et concurrence de nouveaux médias dans
la morosité ambiante les faits divers
contribuent à doper les ventes jusqu'à
son dernier souffle s'il survient un
jour la presse écrite s'accrochera à sa
rubrique fétiche
parce que c'est aussi par la grâce du
fait divers que la presse moderne est
née
[Musique]
Serge Garde et journalistes spécialisés
dans l'histoire des faits divers à
laquelle il a consacré plusieurs
ouvrages ça c'est la c'est la page des
faits divers les anciens numéros du
Petit Journal et de son édition
parisienne le Petit Parisien lui son
précieux dans ses travaux premier
quotidien à très grand tirage c'est un
titre emblématique de la presse
française qui a fondé son succès sur le
fait divers un fait divers à Pantin
il y aura cinq victimes qui va faire
exploser les ventes du Petit Journal
voilà dans les locaux du Petit Journal
la veille d'une exécution il y avait un
calicot pour annoncer l'exécution
[Musique]
en France vient faire célèbre vers 1865
864 va faire monter de 100 000
exemplaires pratiquement le petit
journal quand il se mette à suivre ce
crime qui était un crime et plusieurs
cadavres aux portes de Paris et le
journal voyance là va mettre en
feuilleton pratiquement l'enquête qui va
se tenir parce qu'il ne sera jamais
exactement ce qui s'est passé et cela
qu'on va se rendre compte que le crime
ça marche bien et qu'on peut le tenir
plusieurs jours donc c'est pas d'en
parler le jour où ça arrive et qu'on
crée du feuilleton
l'enquête sur le meurtre du petit
Grégory semble ce soir toucher près de
son but le juge d'instruction a décidé
de la remise en liberté de Bernard
Laroche Jean-Marie Villemin a tué
Bernard Laroche Christine Villemin a été
arrêté cet après-midi Christine Villemin
n'est plus accusé de l'assassinat de son
fils toutes les caméras tournent il y a
des il y a des caméras directes
et ensuite radio et télé vous prendrez
madame Laroche les uns après les autres
que vous aurez 25 ans que cela dure le
petit journal peut aller se rhabiller
record de longévité pour un feuilleton à
succès le meurtre d'un enfant revendiqué
par un corbeau marque le début d'une
partie de Cluedo joué dans des montagnes
secrètes les journalistes qui sont
entrés dans ce fait divers ultime ont vu
leur vie bouleversée correspondant de
libération dans l'Est de la France au
début des années 80 Denis Robert est
l'un d'entre eux quand tu vis ce type
d'événement
cette forme ça change ta manière de voir
le monde et de journalisme en
particulier et puis cette soit tu tu
pètes un plomb tu changes de métier tu
fais une dépression enfin ce qui est
arrivé à certains d'entre nous ou soit
ça te donne une un rapport à
l'information et à la vérité qui est
quand même très particulier tu comprends
que la vérité c'est jamais où on te
montre quoi c'est toujours là tu
vraiment regarder le doigt quoi tout
commence le 16 octobre 1984 au coeur du
petit village de dosselles que traverse
une rivière sont devenus célèbre sur ces
berges un photographe nommé Patrick glas
flash en rafale dans la nuit le doigt
enfoncé sur son déclencheur le scoop
qu'il réalise est un détonateur
médiatique son auteur travaille toujours
pour le même journal régional à Épinal
mais ne s'exprime jamais sur le sujet
pour les 20 ans de la faire il a
néanmoins raconté l'histoire de cette
photo de presse exceptionnelle à son
collègue des faits divers arrivé à
l'entrée de l'éponge j'ai croisé une
fourgonnette de gendarmerie quoi là il
suit la fourgonnette le réflexe issu la
fourgonnette qui l'amène à deux selles
là ils vont un pompier il lui demande ce
qui se passe et on lui annonce qu'on
vient de retrouver le gamin alors il
sort son appareil photo et il a un
appareil photo pour l'anecdote le flash
marche une fois sur 10 quoi
il revient au canard pour faire
développer ses photos et en développant
là il a un choc parce qu'il s'aperçoit
que les pieds et les poignées d'enfance
sont liés avec des cordelettes donc
c'est là qui comprend que c'est un crime
très rapidement
les rédaction nationale dépêche des
dizaines d'envoyés spéciaux les médias
sont accros et bien nourris en info par
l'institution judiciaire le capitaine de
gendarmerie fait une conférence de
presse une fois par jour voire deux fois
par jour et le procure la République met
son plus beau nœud papillon en disant
c'est une affaire extraordinaire c'est
une tapisserie Bernard Laroche le cousin
n'est pas le premier suspect et ne sera
pas non plus le dernier son arrestation
à l'usine en bleu de travail relève de
l'échafaud médiatique les journalistes
répondent en masse à la convocation des
gendarmes pour la mise au fer du
prisonnier Gérard Welzer devient son
avocat et moi quand je vais voir la
roche à la présence à plantes 84 je ne
connais que Sky dans la presse et je le
crois pas
trois mois plus tard Bernard Laroche est
libéré aucune preuve formelle n’est
relevée à son encontre mais une partie
de la presse reste persuadée de sa
culpabilité et continue de colporter
cette hypothèse notamment auprès du père
de Grégory et la libération
de Bernard Laroche qu'est-ce qui vous en
pensez alors
fou de vengeance ce dernier se rend chez
son cousin et le tue il y a une faute
collective de la presse quoi et donc le
Jean-Marie Willemin au moment où il
appuie sur la gachette il est il est il
est chauffé à blanc quoi il y a eu un
discutablement des dérapages et
maintenant ou des avocats ou des
journalistes ou des deux il y a eu des
comportements parfois regrettables il y
a eu des excès il y a eu des fautes
commises et je crois que en toute
objectivité nous devons les uns les
autres battre loyalement notre cool la
roche abattue le fait divers du siècle
en appel là de nouveaux développements
pour durer et à nouveau suspect pourquoi
pas la mer Christine Villemin le
scénario rêvé Christine Villemin a elle
aussi beaucoup changé Hervé Brusini
c'est vrai qu'elle a changé Christine
Villemin aujourd'hui ensemble
inébranlable presque dur chaque jour à
la une de l'actualité sa silhouette
noire traquée par la presse sans répit
aucun sur scène
les rumeurs sont toujours après moi et
puis que j'ai rien à me reprocher pas
l'ombre d'une preuve aucun mobile mais
durant plusieurs années toute la France
va fantasmer sur l'horrible mer
infanticide avant qu'elle ne soit mise
totalement hors de cause
l'affaire Villemin c'est avant tout
l'histoire d'un formidable naufrage
judiciaire la gendarmerie avait sa thèse
la folie savait sa thèse qui évidemment
était contraire opposés bon en fait on
est arrivé à fiasco complet quoi bon
dans cette instruction à rebondissement
le moindre mouvement des enquêteurs est
immédiatement détecté par les
journalistes tu avais un nombre de
suspects restreints dans un territoire
restreint qu'on pouvait écumer qui avait
pas besoin d'être un service de police
qui avec un maillage sur toute la France
un seul journal deux journalistes
pouvait au porte-à-porte essayer
peut-être de trouver des indices et de
de démasquer le coupable quoi
effectivement ils sont pris pour des
routes à billes dès que les gendarmes
interroger quelqu'un poser des questions
les personnes qui avaient pas une grande
expérience de la presse etc en parler
autour d'eux les journalistes étaient au
courant des confidences donc les
informations circulaient puis elle
sortait très vite il y avait des
concurrences entre entre médias les
journalistes sont divisés en deux camps
bien distincts les pros la roche et les
profils chacun est persuadé de la
culpabilité de la mer ou du cousin on
disposant d'un homme dans les deux
parties Paris Match à tout compris et
pour que le choc des photos égale
vraiment le poids des mots l'Hebdo de
Daniel Philippe aqui va négocier des
exclusivité avec les avocats notamment
maître Garreau le Conseil parisien des
villesmain les avocats de Christine et
Jean-Marie Villemin ont eu un rôle
absolument considérable dont ce qui a
été la rumeur autour de la mer etc par
la vente des photos par par le trafic
qu'ils ont fait en coulisse
ils ont fabriqué complètement une image
fausse de de Christine Villemin pour
pour toucher des honoraires c'est aussi
simple que ça cette argent dont maître
Garreau a pu trouver l'origine a pu
bénéficier aux villesmin dans la mesure
où à l'époque Jean-Marie Villemin était
incarcéré il fallait que Christine
Villemin puisse vivre durant plusieurs
mois une bonne centaine de journalistes
parisiens vont s'établir à demeure à
Épinal avec certaines conséquences sur
l'économie locale en 30 ans de
quarantaine j'ai jamais vu revu
ce cet esprit et puis cette ambiance
cette ambiance où arrive une centaine de
80 à 100 personnes tous les soirs
l'affaire Grégory avec tout le respect
que je dois bien sûr aux événements et
voilà mais c'était une période
d'exceptionnel pour nous commercialement
une affaire Grégory c'était quelque
chose il est important alors en chiffres
en chiffre d'affaires au fil du temps
dans la vallée de la Vologne les angles
des papiers et des reportages des vies
faute de suspect vraiment probant
certains médias tant à fonder une
culpabilité collective celle d'une
région et de ses habitants le cliché
d'un vosgien à culture et arriéré
commence à se dessiner c'est quasiment
des explorateurs coloniaux qui arrivent
qui débarquent et qui observe des tribus
de sondages quoi ah mais dans certains
papiers mais c'est exactement ça qui ne
parle même pas de la faire juste comment
sont même pas l'affaire la famille Vima
ou la roche mais commençons les
habitants de la vallée de la Vologne il
y a un côté Fantasia chez les ploucs le
procureur de la République évoquait ce
soir le caractère frustre de certains
témoins de certains oncles et tentent de
Grégory ici la vie est dure la réussite
sociale est rarissime dès qu'on voit un
journaliste maintenant on fait attention
bien entendu
presque agressif
parce que je me répète avec l'image
qu'on a on a voulu nous donner
dans ce maestro médiatique qui est
devenu l'affaire Villemin quelques
reporters ont su conserver une certaine
lucidité écriture distanciée dès les
premiers papiers subtil ironie tout en
non-dit la couverture du jeune pigiste
de Libé est aujourd'hui montré en
exemple dans les écoles de journalistes
j'ai compris assez tôt que mon rôle
était pas de savoir qui était coupable
en quelque sorte mais mon rôle était de
raconter cette folie qui qui était en
train de de s'emparer de tout le monde
et une folie qui s'est comment dire qui
s'est disséminé sur la longueur quoi
c'est la durée des au début on se dit ça
va durer des jours puis après ça a duré
des semaines puis après des mois puis
après des années et on voit aujourd'hui
on est quand même des décennies plus
tard et on est toujours là quoi toi on
parlait moi je suis là très pondre chose
que je fais rarement quand tu le sais
mais bon
[Musique]
Palais de justice de Paris 21 novembre
2009 11h une audience particulière va
s'ouvrir dans la 11e chambre du tribunal
correctionnel petite affaire de calomnie
et de falsification de documents mes
grands procès à dimension politique 2
heures plus tard les premiers
journalistes et techniciens affluent
dans le hall la mission confiée par leur
rédaction immortalisée l'arrivée des
prévenus le positionnement est
déterminant là l'entrée ils vont vu
comment elle est disposer si tu veux ils
vont rentrer direct donc l'idée c'est de
venir un peu en avant et d'arriver à
avoir
l'image de l'arrivée évidemment et
essayer d'avoir un sonore et là entre
ici et l'entrée là-bas on a une distance
suffisante pour essayer d'avoir tout ça
c'est ça la logique tu arrives il faut
que tu te mettes vite vite devant
l'entrée de la salle en fait TF1
s'occuper d'attraper les premières
arrivées et les sons les autres vont
être sûr qu'on ait l'image des entrées
dans la salle
l'asso est lancée ruée vers l'image et
le son en ordre dérangé premier objectif
des fantassins de l'info un présumé
faussaire et son escort qui tente une
Persée vers le prétoire
autre prévenu très attendu un capitaine
d'industrie accusé de calomnie tout est
mis en œuvre pour arracher un mot
présumé corbeau
sans succès
[Musique]
dehors on retrouve un abonné des
histoires de corbeaux
mais dans cette affaire Denis Robert à
sa place réservée sur le bon des accusés
je suis poursuivé pour journaliste
Pierre comme chef d'accusation
française
c'est une expérience aussi mais c'est
comme au théâtre sauf que je paye pas ma
place quoi
sur les premiers 20 mètres la motte se
montre un peu timide face aux confrères
mais viens vite les pandores sont
contraintes d'employer la technique bien
éprouvée du bélier mais certains ne
l'entendent pas de cette oreille
doucement doucement
non c'est pas beau
il arrive ici et film déclaration
attention à ne pas manquer la
déclaration du procès
je suis ici par
l'acharnement d'un homme
Nicolas Sarkozy mais au fait comment on
prononce Clearstream en langage JT c'est
un peu la même chose que dans tous les
process sauf que ce procès est
particulièrement compliqué c'est-à-dire
qu'on a dans le meilleur des cas deux
minutes trois minutes trois minutes et
demi pour expliquer ce dossier qui est
un peu un dossier en poupées russes
de donner une atmosphère déjà il a c'est
déjà le c'est déjà dû être parti quoi
nous avocats de ténors du baron qui dès
le départ montre un peu que ça va être
ça va être ouais ça va être violent quoi
et fait de manche tout y passe quoi et
c'est vrai que c'est des stars
[Musique]
qu'on peut expliquer sur un format de
minutes c'est c'est ce show médiatique
ce chaud politique ces rivalités dans
les années du pouvoir qui qui font qu'on
en arrive là quand on a un ancien
Premier ministre et un président de la
République qui s'affrontent forcément il
y a une notion de spectacle aussi qui
fait que les gens puissent s'y
intéresser même si la justice devrait
pas être un spectacle mais des facto
elle
dans cette ambiance survolté la
confraternité a des limites que la
promiscuité finit parfois par dépasser
quand même attendez
TF1
part arrêter
parce que moi je rigole
tu vois
faut arrêter de donner ah les gars de
TF1 la généralisation déjà
ma place
non mais Olivier profession teneur du
barreau de Paris signe particulier aime
sortir en forêt avant les principales
éditions d'information de la journée la
justice attendait se faire d'abord dans
l'opinion publique qui est informé que
par la presse et ça risque de fausser un
jugement donc il y a deux temps il y a
un temps médiatique et un temps
judiciaire le temps médiatique est très
rapide en temps réel le temps judiciaire
qui apporte la vraie vérité arrive
souvent des années après est-ce que
justement ce temps médiatique qui prend
tant d'importance c'est pas un obstacle
à la sérénité des débats quelque part
ça pose une difficulté mais il est
normal il est normal que le bien public
soit tenu au courant de tout
ici justement résumé la principale
source d'information de l'opinion
Clément vellerinald et le chef du
service judiciaire de l'édition
nationale de France 3 Nathalie Perez et
sa monteuse réalise le reportage qui va
être diffusé dans l'édition de 19h30
on est juste bien
[Musique]
Clément a bien préparé son direct le
reportage de Nathalie est bouclé tout
semble bien rouler
mais parfois la magie de la télé éprouve
quelques difficultés à opérer
[Musique]
il faut que vous mettiez le direct
d'abord le sujet après qu'est-ce que je
t'ai dit le JT est lancé Clément fait un
sans faute en direct et le sujet de
Nathalie est finalement bien passé bravo
c'est bien passé
en un mois de procès on va tirer des
milliers de portraits les acteurs de
notre dernière histoire judiciaires vont
connaître des expositions médiatiques à
géométrie très variable ont la qualifié
de procès de la décennie il commence
déjà à sombrer dans l'oubli la faute à
l'actualité
et sa mémoire instantanée
pour retour à l'union de Reims pour
l'épilogue de cette histoire grand débat
entre deux rédacteurs en chef sur les
rapports ambigus qu'entretiennent les
faits divers et la classe politique une
politique peut pas inventer des
situations humaines il les constatent
son rôle à lui c'est de les gérer donc
il les constatent dans la vie
quotidienne si les inventés peut
paraître parfaitement difficile c'est
vrai aussi les politiques ont tendance à
réagir à utiliser l’émotion à un moment
donné pour justement rebondir sur un
certain nombre de faits divers mais
entre le gouvernement de l'émotion et le
gouvernement de la raison il y a un
fossé qui n'est pas forcément au profit
du politique au sens strict du terme
le sociologue Pierre Bourdieu l'a dit
les faits divers font diversion
il détourne l'attention de l'opinion
débarrasser
en 7 ans on a voté 30 lois sur la
justice la sécurité et l'immigration
pour punir les bandes proscrire les
cagoules ou établir les peines plancher
pour mineur les faits divers parfois ça
fait vraiment peur
[Musique]